[Music]
[Applause]
the bills are going to play the Patriots
coming up this weekend Eric wood is a
former bills Center and his fourth
season is the Bills radio color analyst
Eric thanks for joining us let me start
at the end of Monday night's game
when the players are in the locker room
were they told anything about possibly
staying or playing that game on Tuesday
yeah I'm not sure exactly how That Shook
out I was in the broadcast booth and to
my knowledge all the focus was on Demar
and they simply were saying look we're
not playing this game tonight and I
can't imagine that anyone would have
been an emotional state to play that
game within the 48-hour rule that they
would have needed to get that game in
what were you told when you were in the
broadcast Booth about first of all
demar's health and then the situation
involving going back to Buffalo
we were just simply uh waiting on
information as it came like everyone
else was in the stadium and at first no
one knew the severity of the situation
uh unfortunately we've become accustomed
to seeing carts come on the field and
even at times ambulances but based upon
the player's reaction the coach's
reaction the way they lined up everybody
to to block the viewing of CPR given to
tomorrow in the field for almost 10
minutes we knew that this was a a much
different situation than we're used to
seeing in a in a football game tell us
who Demar is
Demar Hammond is a special young man I
actually had the pleasure of covering
him in college when he was at the
University of Pittsburgh and I was
working at ESPN and we'd sit down for
production meetings with Pat narduzzi
and they had guys drafted higher than
him in the draft but he would always
talk about what a special young man
tomorrow is and then also talk about how
he would play a long time in the NFL
that's just the type of player and
person that he is and then like anything
when you get to the NFL and your
platform gets magnified often that
impact that you could have on others
gets impacted and I love how over these
last couple days so much has been shared
about the impact that the bar has made
on his teammates the Buffalo Community
the Pittsburgh Community and then so
many others through tour drives in this
Foundation he's just truly a special
young man what did you see on the play
and it just looked like a routine hit
Dan what I saw is very similar to what
you saw it looked like a routine play
and then when he stood up and went back
down
automatically you think head injury just
the way he he collapsed you think likely
a head injury potentially spinal it's
you know this this Cardiac Arrest is not
something that was on anybody's minds
and so it went to commercial break and
while we were watching in the stadium
silence fell over maybe the loudest
stadium I've heard this entire season
silence Falls over the stadium as
everybody's watching The Player's
reaction and then obviously the
situation just threw more and more tense
as Demar didn't get up and we we've just
become so used to seeing as well you
know a guy gets carted off or even as
he's going into an ambulance you get
that wave or a thumbs up but in this
situation we knew after a few minutes
that that likely wasn't coming
but then you're on the air you're on
radio and you have to describe all of
this like how how do you get through
that hour-long period or however long
you guys were on after the injury and
then realizing that the game had been
canceled
yeah so at first you know they're asking
me a former player's perspective how do
you compartmentalize this and continue
playing and there's been many times that
I've had teammates carted off and it's
an emotional period and then you just
have to go back and do your job and this
was not one of those situations though
and and it got to the point where the
players were so emotional the coaches
were so emotional
I I went even as far as to say if if the
bills were forced to Forfeit the game
and take a loss and lose hopefield
advantage in the one seed so be it do
what you have to do to get back in the
locker room and and focus all your
attention on DeMar I was wondering
though we're talking Eric wood he's a
former Buffalo Bills Center in his
fourth season as the Bills radio color
analyst Joe Buck reported a couple of
times the players were told to get ready
they had a five minute window to compose
themselves and resume play were you guys
told anything about the possibility of
them continuing that game
we weren't told anything we saw those
reports through ESPN as well and you
know since then the league is denied and
ESPN has kind of stood by the fact that
that information was relayed to them I'm
hoping what happened in the situation
was you know people that were not in the
stadium did not understand the severity
of the situation so they were simply
saying in times of prolonged period uh
for someone injured that teams are given
a five-minute period to warm back up
they don't necessarily have to go right
back into playing that is simply the
rule and not what they were going to
impose necessarily on this situation I'm
not sure exactly what was said or
communicated during that time I'll also
say that while the NFL is not perfect
and Roger Goodell and his team aren't
perfect and neither are these teams and
I just feel like there's a certain
amount of Grace that needs to be given
to a completely unprecedented situation
on the field what do you expect out of
the bills this weekend against New
England
it's tough to say Dan because you know
those guys are still so emotional the
the mental emotional uh stress those
guys are going through still today and I
know they did a lot yesterday to try and
mitigate that and the bills have been on
the front end of trying to pour into
their players over the years through
whether it's emotional issues mental
health issues whatever it may be they've
kind of been on the front end of that
but that that that staff and all all the
help that they provided they're they're
on full task force now because a lot of
those guys are traumatized from from
what they saw and you know I know from
coming back from broken legs and ACLS
whatever it may be that it could be
tough to step on the field that next
time a little bit of hesitancy and then
you then you get back to normal and how
long it takes these guys to get back to
normal it has yet to be seen I know the
preparation for this upcoming game is
going to be distracted you have a game
coming up against the Patriots where you
know it's winning in for them the Bill's
not sure of how the the results will be
canceled from the last game could have a
lot at stake as well on the field when
you consider
you know if they win against Cincinnati
and win against New England they're the
number one overall seed you get that bye
week and you host throughout the
playoffs but I can tell you that the
result of that game the seating for the
playoffs in a lot of cases will be the
farthest thing from their minds today
were you on the plane ride home
I was and uh home for me is in
Louisville Kentucky so I I drove back
from Cincinnati that night uh and just
and just stayed in communication with as
many people as I could
Eric thank you we appreciate your time
good luck uh with the Patriots game and
the postseason thank you again
I appreciate it Dave that's uh Eric wood